The joe rogan experience.
Have you heard of a guy
named Peter pop off?
He's a pastor.
Was televangelists guys,
what did he do?
I saw him the other day.
I watched a,
I was sleeping on the
couch and I woke up in his,
he had one of those shows on a page
shows commercials and I was amazed what,
what woke me up cause I was kind of
like half listening to while sleeping.
What was amazed as how the
things that they say in it,
it just seemed to illegal.
Like they were like,
you like,
oh you know we're going to
send you some miracle water.
This water is,
you know,
miracle water,
you're going to open up these envelopes.
And then they start showing
like testimonials like of
people and they're like,
you know,
I sent in my,
or I read the letters and then just a
week later I got a new house and a car and
then the next person was like,
I got $200,000 and then
there's other ones,
like a guy just walked up and
gave me a check for $15 million.
And it was,
it was like the most fake as shit ever.
And so then I started really researching
this guy and there's all these videos
about him online,
I guess he's been ripping
people off for a long time,
and one of the best videos is one
where he just goes up and he goes,
where's we're so Ansel,
so and so's here.
Like,
listen,
let's say Tina,
Tina Fey,
where are you?
Where are you at?
And comes up and goes,
I heard you have arthritis and you're
here because you want to get rid of this
author.
Itus and stuff like that.
And the whole time his
wife is just pumping,
she had a thing on,
it was on one of those 2020
or something like that.
Yeah.
I know we talked about this in the past.
I'm pretty sure maybe it
was on another podcast,
but I was amazed that he's
still allowed to do this.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well that guy
named one is not,
but it's almost like,
it's so ridiculous.
It's like the most
ridiculous hustle lever.
It's like,
who are they tricking?
The only people that tricking or like
they're almost like mentally challenged.
Oh yeah.
People with no hope when you're,
when you're done,
we just robots when you're down to being
convinced that there's a miracle water
out there that is going
to come in the mail,
be of the postal service
and it's going to look,
it's going to change your fortune,
right?
Yeah.
That's the one,
one of these things somewhere along the
line they used to ask for donations but
then somewhere along the line they,
uh,
they realized that they could sell
things and they started like selling like
holy water and selling
like prayer services and,
and,
and telling people that
you would plant a seed.
So I'll be like,
spend $90,
Jill,
last $90.
He would come back to you in 10 fold.
The Bible says,
and it would come out with
some crazy fucking was that,
um,
the Guy Creflo dollar is my favorite
because it's got a dollar in his name.
I mean,
you're a pastor and your
fucking name is dollar.
What's your real name or names like that?
Peter Popoff.
Have you ever met any
other pop offs before?
This guy's got to have a
different real name though.
He must have a real name.
What's his real name?
Wow.
His real name is Creflo
Augustus dollar junior.
Wow.
This is real fucking name.
It's got a bachelor of
science and education
south.
Their target shit.
Smacking people.
My favorite Robert Tilton,
you know he is,
he,
he probably seen him the,
there's a um,
a viral video of him farting.
Like he's like,
he talks to tons a lot on a show too.
He'll go,
it's hilarious.
See if he could pull up Robert Tilton
talking in tongues because it's some of
the most ridiculous shit ever.
But a one,
I'll never forget this
one thing that he said.
He said,
every time you write a check to me,
Satan gets a black.
Wow.
But it doesn't,
part of you think that if you're dumb
enough to to send him that money,
like,
so what?
So a guy got you with the
dumbest trick of all time.
Like you really thought that
money was going to gone.
You really thought that money is
going to give the devil a black guy.
If you really thought that you,
you're fucking stupid and
we're not looking after you.
Right?
One of the sky things that
this Peter Popoff does,
he also sends you a barley cake from,
you know the Bible where it's like
kind of like that little bread you eat.
And he goes,
ah.
He goes in this commercial,
he goes and we make it with the exact
ingredients that they say in the Bible and
Blah,
blah,
blah.
Well then if you look up his
zeal for 12 in the Bible,
it says,
and you should eat it as barley cakes
and bake it using fuel of human waste.
So human way.
So,
so in the,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
When they know it does,
you want to vet,
please type it into
clinical for 12 easy e.
Dot.
Sylaria K I,
hold on,
hold on.
Four 24 12 four 12 yeah,
you're,
you're thinking about the weed law,
but he killed for 12 hours since
I read up on my good old days.
He keels so this is all new to me.
Bake it with Dung that cometh
out of man in their sight.
Hold on a second or cooked with,
oh my God,
thou shalt bake it with Dung that
cometh out of man in their sight.
You mean to study the Bible
and Cook You bread with Shit?
Have you ever tried my purple barley cake?
You fucking imagine how dumb people are.
That really hurts my brain.
Do you know what [inaudible] might've
been a tripper cause the Zico was also
where the first depictions
of Ufos came from.
Here.
Let me pull that up.
[inaudible] was known for,
there's um,
there's a,
like a bible quote that
people bring up all the time.
We see a Ufo.
Oh,
I bet people were seeing a lot of
things after eating a bunch of shit.
Males,
they're eating fucking shit cakes all day,
throwing up.
Almost time it was a wheel within a wheel.
It was God's chariot guys with boats.
They had all the animals.
You think we should prepare the
barley cake in a different way?
No,
no.
It's great.
I'm kind of trying to find
what a stupid fucking culture.
Yeah,
I cook it with Shit.
Okay,
dad,
should I write that down on paper?
I fit something for my son because I
got so obsessed with this administered
that.
So when I found that out,
I,
I had tweeted something like olive
garden was like [inaudible] oh four 12 or
something like that and all these
people got pissed off that I was doing.
I didn't doing Bible scriptures.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Well they read that though.
Yeah,
they figured it out.
How do you not read that
and just start laughing?
You telling me to Cook Shit.
Cakes.
Fuck.
The Bible says Cook Shit cakes.
That's just one more
dumb thing in the Bible.
God down.
I was so tired of people
pretending that book's awesome.
I'm so tired.
You stop that shit stupid.
Okay,
here.
Here's the,
here's a quote.
And I looked and behold,
a whirlwind came out of the north,
a great cloud and a fire enfolding itself
in brightness was about it and out of
the midst thereof as the color of
amber out of the midst of the fire.
Okay.
How was that Efl?
Hmm.
That's okay.
Somebody putting two points
together that don't go together.
Oh,
wait a minute.
This stuff.
Hold on.
Listen to this.
Also,
out of the midst thereof came the likeness
of four living creatures and this was
their appearance.
They had the likeness of a man woe.
After everyone had four faces in,
every one had four wings and their feet
were straight and the sole of their feet
was like the soul of a calf's foot and
they sparkled like the color of burnished
brass.
What a trippy book.
People are like,
oh my God,
it's so real.
I hear God's words when
you're saying these things,
God is speaking to me through your words.
Please run on.
And they had the hands of men under
their wings on their four sides and they
had,
and they four had their
faces and their waste.
Somebody might have just made all this
up and me like an asshole as reading
these fake Bible quotes shitting
all over the Bible and the aliens.
But guess what?
I don't care.
I'm not,
I'm not reading any further.
It's,
it seems like if this is,
if this really is as
he kills it says it is.
God dammit.
It's all nuttiness.
They walked up with their
four faces and they said,
why are you guys cooking things in Shit?
And the living creatures ran in,
returned as the appearance
of a flash of lightning.
Now as I behold,
the living creatures,
behold one wheel upon the earth by the
living creatures with his four faces.
These guys were tripping hard eating shit.
Cakes.
Yeah,
losing their mind.
What grows on shit.
Mushrooms.
That's right.
Leave your shit.
Kicks out the cover with mushrooms.
Eat your shit cakes.
Chop your balls off.
Start talking nutty man.
When those went,
these went,
and when those stood still these stood
and when those were lifted up from the
earth,
the wheels were lifted up.
That guy is this gloss of Lelea.
That guy's just,
that's a word salad.
That guy's high as fuck.
He just rambling.
Highest fuck on shit.
The same thing in Joshua tree one time.
This is the stuff,
by the way,
that they kept in.
Okay.
Oh,
it is already,
what the fuck's on?